chasing the ruler
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is so funny I'm really enjoying
myself
um love the dog love the chihuahuas so
cute this bowl cut is that a bouquet I
don't know that that was everything and
let me just say if you grew up and you
had a bowl cut and you didn't end up as
a school shooter you're probably a
handsome individual
because nobody will raise on a bowl cut
and ugly didn't go on to shoot schools
or you're just in jail
if you're in high school somebody got a
bowl cut in your class be nice
I might save your life oh this is so
zoomed in all the glasses I got this guy
this guy the black guy and the school
shooter the school shooter
um
um let's see she's definitely getting
rid of like the Indian who was just like
body posing for Isis yeah yeah he's
definitely going okay unfortunately I'm
eliminating number three
let's go let's go how did I predict that
she didn't want to get with the Isis
dude she wants head she doesn't want to
get beheaded
oh my gosh you're so cool
I'm not gonna lie I'm like wait he looks
like he's a whole different race yeah
it's good I was like did we say Indian
our reaction to what the guy ended up
looking I was like I was like yeah man
you know what I didn't think he was
gonna come out looking like a K-pop Star
gone dark you know what I'm saying oh
we said Indian
can you give me a little backstory
behind the picture
this is where I first came to uh the
United States I was from the Philippines
yeah oh that's so sick I was like I was
like 13. um contestant number one can I
get a little backstory behind the
picture like the glow stick the dog how
old were you well I think this is about
sixth grade uh that's my dog his name is
Rafi he's got big beady eyes so I'm from
Hawaii my sister was telling me that I
should grow up my hair to look like one
of those cool Surfer boys oh damn he's
winning
I said I said school shooter he's
winning how's that school shooter turns
up he's like no uh he's a dude Aloha
phone calls her he's winning hey man do
you believe they're getting a little bit
more International with this making it
harder on me how you think you've
changed since this picture I definitely
lost the glasses that's that's a start
and uh I used to be like really short so
I somewhat grew a little bit a little
bit yeah you're getting eliminated too
brother
yeah you're definitely getting
eliminated this round hey next round
listen you didn't have to say a little
bit you just said I grew though and just
leave it up in the air you didn't have
to mention your height but the moment
you said you grew a little bit it's like
I grew but I'm not satisfied with how
much growth I had because I'm still not
part of the six foot Master race
um and the braids are gone
um number six
um how old were you in this picture I'm
not gonna lie this is the kind of
picture that [ __ ] news articles would
put out yeah after they found out like
yo this guy was such a good child then
he joined Isis like the the mom would
hold up yeah my son would never
meanwhile they got videos of him
beheading 10 people this is between one
and six easy easy
the rest of the three getting limited
let me see if I'm wrong yeah
um what made you want to glow up did it
happen naturally or did you put effort
into it um to be honest it kind of just
happened naturally I don't wear glasses
anymore I definitely use contacts um and
then yeah just just kind of taking pride
in my appearance you know I don't have
the same haircut anymore either puberty
puberty is a great thing
[Music]
I uh I don't have this haircut anymore
puberty is a great thing
hey you sound like you have a wonderful
voice I wonder what kind of dress you're
wearing yeah no I think you look good in
that that sounds I can't see it but I
can imagine it my mind's eye the same
way I can imagine us taking a walk down
the street
what's her name Sandra nah it's nice
puberty is a wonderful thing trust me
babe I don't look nothing like that
picture no more
but you definitely want to see what I
look like now choose me
that was Bill Clinton
she looked a little bit like Monica
Lewinsky
even the models look a little bit
unstable she my secretary I might ask
for a [ __ ] too
okay unfortunately I'm gonna eliminate
contestant number two
um
[Music]
yeah they got a lot of [ __ ] Asian pop
stars up in this beach man well they
this California yeah I'm just saying
shout out listen we was talking [ __ ]
about your voice but I mean yeah you did
come out looking you know you did your
thing nice to meet you once I saw
everyone I was like I knew this game
over I'm going to eliminate contestant
number
[Music]
it was at this moment that she knew she
[ __ ] up oh my gosh you're so handsome
[Music]
thank you I appreciate it how's it going
Jason the ruler
you know what else man this is some kind
of gay because he's a thing right I'm
out here just thinking like man whatever
now these [ __ ] come out and in my head
I'm like man these [ __ ] are handsome
and I'm like why am I one thing that's
not gay it's not it's nah but you know I
don't want to think about this [ __ ] she
got issues
uh yeah thank you I appreciate it yeah
how's it going nice to meet you yeah
thanks for that once he locked Eiser he
put in the [ __ ] boy hey how's it going
yeah do you realize how badly you [ __ ]
up yeah I got a little bit taller but
you know what it was always being
that dick
[Laughter]
I love your style I love yours nice I
like your smile
well it's great meeting you too thank
you
um let's see you said you play World of
Warcraft do you are you still a big
gamer today that's all you remember
um I play league but like I do cool
people stuff too he's a i play league
listen nobody who plays League does cool
people stuff everybody plays leagues are
[ __ ] degenerates who play a game made
for rage baiters okay I know because I
used to play league and then I realized
I wanted good things and happiness in my
life
no I used to play Halo and I've played
League like a couple times in my life oh
for real did you like it yeah um you
know I'm I'm someone that likes going
outside and like talking to other people
more
time to come back is nicer in order to
come back
did you like League um I prefer touching
grass
um I work out about four days a week
it's not like super important in my life
but I do like to keep active I walk
everywhere because I don't have a car
you know a car in L.A yo that's so
that's so facts bro listen listen I
lived in Delhi for two years without a
car let me tell you that is not livid
you struggle in La without a car listen
you struggle in a car without a car
you're risking your life you're walking
everywhere brush listen the homeless
population the less you can give them
access to you the better when you walk
there's no barrier to entry listen [ __ ]
it's like it's like having a bank
it's like having a bank with no doors no
guards and no alarm system these
[ __ ] are coming so all you can
do is fend off the wave honestly
honestly this is the biggest difference
that I've noticed between Los Angeles
homeless people and everywhere else in
the [ __ ] world I don't know what is
about West Coast homeless people
but it's not just that they crazy it's
like they crazy and they're ready to let
you know like they don't even want money
sometimes they just want to get in your
space and be like wow we were in L.A
you're telling me about the homeless
people and we get off the car to eat a
bit and then we see a homeless dude
talking to a dude with a skate yeah he's
like oh you're not gonna let me try
Escape
ah man you a jackass [ __ ] you
you walked off he didn't ask for money
he didn't ask for nothing to eat he just
went let me try to [ __ ] Escape yeah
the whole argument about a skateboard
that it was nice you're lucky I know you
got to hear the homeless person that
speaks English I know I'm not even
talking about the homeless people who
speak Spanish I'm talking about the
homeless people who don't speak yeah
excuse me sir
like like Jurassic Park
ah
yeah
and you know what's crazy is even when
they're going they look at you like you
dumb [ __ ] you don't understand
what I just said that's homeless people
you try to offer them money they look
insulted
hey man listen I'm just it's a unique
experience first elimination this round
is gonna be contestant number one you
mentioned Fitness in your life I'm not
looking to be a gym couple oh hi hello
nice to meet you nice to meet you thank
you I mean my dog's still cute
he's like
yeah I didn't miss out I think I'm gonna
eliminate contestant number six
hi oh my gosh you look so different yeah
nice to meet you you went into the
Chunky Glass
hi oh my gosh it's so nice nice meeting
you Eli nice to meet you here
um yeah I mean I'll just text her let's
see if it goes she likes me and I mean
I'll take the opportunity I'll take my
shot I'm pretty proud of my decision
should I flip it
okay here we go
wow humble beginnings for sure
[Laughter]
this guy Hey listen if there's one thing
that Lee teaches you is how to be
[ __ ] toxic shout out to you my man he
definitely ranked yeah he 100 played
rank yeah all right what'd you think
hey man Jubilee got a good cast they got
a good cast
I don't even know how you vented these
[ __ ] you said Hey Hey listen if
you were ugly but you a hot [ __ ]
we're gonna need 10 pictures
and you guys got them you got them
because those glow ups were crazy yeah
we're good we're crazy but I'm not even
gonna lie man if we did our glow ups I
feel like I got a better glow up than
you did
yeah cause you looked uglier
I got a better Club yeah I was all right
yeah I feel like even you as a kid you
still must have been like
something absolutely I was dorky as [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah but you're a dorky
by like Behavior not by look no I feel
like even if I would have seen you as a
kid I'm like if I was a police officer
I'd still shoot you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah you two meat no oh yeah no no
no trust me as a kid I look I didn't
look threatening I just look like an
alien I look weird yeah it looked like a
whole lot I was like my ears like you
guys don't notice it but my ears stick
out like crazy so on a small head and a
small body I used to get called Dumbo
elephant all the time plus that forehead
yeah
nobody thought I was threatening
everybody thought like Hey listen we're
so happy we could finally import you
from Ethiopia you know what I mean you
know you don't got the Flies on your
face no more welcome they weren't
looking at me like that no no no they
won't look at me like that they want to
go shoot me I was too like Miss King you
know miskiness oh
that was for me as a kid maybe one day
we'll show you guys kid pictures maybe
maybe
not two million two million Subs make
sure you subtle yeah that's like three
if we get to two million remind us and
we'll I will I will do something with
this
yeah we're getting there we're getting
there we've been growing this month
anyways leave your comments below